when I go down the slope it takes me
three seconds to get from zero to sixty
miles an hour I honestly can't explain
what it feels like even after 15 years
of doing this floor
my name is Sarah Hendrickson and I'm an
Olympic ski jumper ski jumping is a
sport where I go down a two track slope
at 55 miles an hour and when the slope
ends I jump flying about a football
field in length in the air when I'm
getting ready to go
the smell is of the fresh air from the
trees and the snow in the area and the
feeling of cold brisk air on my face
when I put my goggles on I know it's
time to go
[Music]
my eyesight when I'm going down the
slope is right in front of the tips of
my skis my skis are bouncing up and down
in the track against the ice it feels
like clatter if you hear it it's like a
long Bowl the flight takes three seconds
but honestly time slows down and it
feels like an eternity where I get to
enjoy flying as I'm flying I can't hear
anything it's completely silent all
around the wind on my body feels like
when you put your hand out of a car
window going 60 miles an hour moving it
up and down you can feel the lift and
drag it has on your hand
that's like ski jumping but for your
whole body as I'm flying I'm totally
alone I'm in control of all my senses
and all my movements it's the best
feeling in the world
you
[Music]
you